[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ عمر سيتولي في مدينه
جوهانسبورغ بجنوب افريقيا واسلم وهو في
الخامسه عشره من عمره ليبدا في تعلم اللغه
العربيه من اجل فهم للقران الكريم
حفظ كتاب الله كاملا في سنه واحده واتقن
فنون التجويد من خلال تردده على المجالس
والحلقات القرانيه المنتشره في مساجد جنوب
افريقيا
انا اسلمت عمري تقريبا عشره سنوات الحمد
لله بمن وفضل من الله سبحانه وتعالى ثم
انا لحقت بمدرسه في جوهانسبيك هناك واحد
بدا بحرف الهجائيه الف باء تاء ثاء ج ح
والحمد لله ثم بعد ذلك واحد عرف ان يقرا
القران نظره
وبدانا نحفز القران وكان الحمد لله يعني
بمن وفضل من الله سبحانه وتعالى كان عندي
قوه ذاكره
وحفظ القران من خلال سنه
القران وانا عمري 13 سنه
فالحمد لله حافظت القران وبعد ذلك
بدات ان اتقن في التجويد وادرس
التجويد لمقدمه الجزريه تحفه الاطفال
ثم بدات الحمد لله بعد ذلك يعني نصلي في
المساجد التراويح
ومن هناك
الله سبحانه وتعالى اتاح عليه الفرصه ان
نشارك في مسابقه الدوليه في مصر في
الجزائر في الكويت في السعوديه
الحمد لله
وبعد ذلك يعني عندما رجعت يعني زاد لي
الهمه ان ان يعني ان ندرس القران
وادرس في القراءات وكل شيء فالحمد لله
بدات ان ادرس في القراءه السبعه
فخصل قراءه السبعه ثم بعد ذلك اخذت لقناه
العشر
وكنا نحفظ
الشاطبيه الاستاذنا كان مشد شويه في الحفظ
المتون الحمد لله حفظنا الجزريه والشاطبيه
وقرانا عليه القران الحمد لله بفضل من
الله سبحانه وتعالى الحمد لله يعني
المسلمين الان في جنوب افريقيا ثمن من
ناحيه الحكومه زال يقولون انها اتنين
بالمئه
لكن
من ناحيه انا الحمد لله العدد المسلمين
زادت الان في جنوب افريقيا واحد قد يكون
ممكن خمسه بالمئه
مع الاسف الشديد يعني الاحباب الذين هم
وصلوا الى جنوب افريقيا المسلمين ناحيه
المسلمين هم الهنود
وكان هناك العنصريه ايام الايام العنصريه
فماذا فعل العنصريه جعل الهنود يعني
منغلقين في يعني ساكنين فيما بعد وهم
كانوا هؤلاء اذكياء جدا لان عرف ان له جعل
الاحباب المسلمين الهنود يعيشون مع
المواطنين هنا الافارقه من هذا الناحيه
سينتشر الاسلام
فهذا كان من ناحيه الاسلام المسلمين لهم
كان جيل لانهم كانوا منغلقين مع بعض وكان
اهتموا باسلامهم فقط ولكن من ناحيه الدعوه
للمسلمين هذا كان في نوع من سلبيه يعني
جعل الفكر ان هذا الدين الاسلام ليست انما
هي دين لاناس خاصه للهنود فقط او الناس
البيض الناس البيضاء او هكذا لم يرى كانها
هي اسلام لكل الناس عامه اسود ام احمر ام
عجب ام عربه لكل الناس عامه فهذا هو
المشكله الان والحمد لله الناس الناس هناك
في مؤسسات دعوه الان اصبح الناس شويه
يفهمون ان هذا الاسلام دين عامه دين
للاسود الاحمر للابيض لاي واحد هذا هو
المسلم في الجنوب افريقيا ما زال العدد في
المواطنين قليله شويه ما زال العدد شويه
قليله جدا والحمد لله يعني فيه في حركه او
فيه جهد شويه وان شاء الله عن قريب سنه
هناك ثمر عظيم ان شاء الله يسمعنا فتح
عظيم ان شاء الله
انا تاثرت كثيرا بالشيخ محمود خليل الحصري
كنا نسمعه كثير ونحن اطفال في المركز لان
الشيخ الاستاذ كان يهتم يقول الشيخ خليل
الحصري لو تسمعه تسمع كل حرف الذي ينطقها
وهذا يساعدك كثيرا لو انت مثلا انت لا
تفهم العربيه احيانا لا تفهم القواعد
التجويد الشيخ يقول هذا ادغام هذا لابد ان
يكون مرقق وهذا يكون مخخمه فاحيانا هذا
يكون يصعب عليك لانك هذا ليس لغتك اللغه
العربيه وهو يريد ان يفهمك باللغه
الانجليزيه الذي ايضا ليست لغتك لان انا
لغه المحليه وهو لا يفهم اللغه المحليه
الزول او السؤال او السوجو فيفهمك باللغه
الانجليزيه ونحن بعضنا نحن جينا من قرى
وهناك في القريه ما يتكلمون الانجليزيه
فيكون عن الفهم صعبه شويه فيكون سهل لو
واحد يسمع فيسمع الشيخ الحليل الخصري
ويسمع كيف يرقق كيف يفخم كيف ينطق هذا
الحرف وانما الشيخ يقول له رقق هذا الحرف
افخمها افتحها يقول لك الفهم يكون سهل
ويكون سهل فاثرني الشيخ خليل الحصري وطبعا
كنا نسمع كثير من المشايخ المصريه الشيخ
عبد الباسط عبد الصمد
من المشايخ الامام الحرم الشيخ عبد الرحمن
السديسي الشيخ شريم هم الذين كنا نسمعهما
نحن اطفال صغار الحمد لله الله يجزيهم خير
الجزاء
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرج
[موسيقى]
يم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
هل اتيك حديث موسى
اذ ناديه ربه
بالواد
المقدس طوى
اذهب الى فرعون
انه طريق
فقل هل لك الى
ان تزكي
واهديك الى ربك فتخشى
فاراه الايه الكبرى
فكذب
وعصفم ادبر يسعي
فحشر
فنادي فقال انا ربكم الاعلى
فاخذه الله
نكال الاخره والاولى
[موسيقى]
ان في ذلك
لعبره
[موسيقى]
لمن يخشى
اانتم اشد خلقا ام الس
[ضحك]
بنيها
رفع
سمكها
فسوها
واغطش ليلها
واخرج ضحيها
والارض بعد ذلك تحيها
اخرج منها
ماءها وما ارعيها
والجبال
اوصيها
متاعا لكم ولانعامكم
فاذا
جاءت
الطاعه الكبرى
يوم
يتذكر
الانسان ما سعى
وبرزت الجحيم لمن
صدق الله العظيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يتولى القارئ عمر سيتولي الامامه لصلاه
التراويح في المساجد الكبرى بجنوب افريقيا
ويتولى التدريس القران الكريم في المدارس
القرانيه كما يشارك في المؤتمرات
والمسابقات القرانيه التي تقام سنويا في
بلاده وخارجها
القران الكريم هي زادت لحبه للقران الكريم
وطبعا تعرف لو انا لو مثلا انا انا مواطن
من جنوب افريقيا من اسره غير مسلمه وانما
تذهب الى المسابقه ترى واحد من غانا واحد
من من السنغال واحد من ملاه واحد من هذه
الدول فتشعر انك انت لست وحيد في ناس
كثيره فارقه مثلك يعني حافظين القران
وماهرين فيها فتريد ان تقول مثلهم او افضل
منهم احيانا فهذا يعني زادت لحبي للقران
وزادت انني يعني اجتهد كثيرا واكون ان شاء
الله مثلهم يعني في القران الكريم وايضا
يعني زالت لحب القران ان يعني جعلت
للمسؤوليه ان ادرس
وبالخصوص يعني المواطنين من جنوب افريقيا
القران الكريم يعني يعني
اشعرت لان هناك مسؤوليه عظيمه عندما
ذهبت رايت ناس كثير المشايخ
والمشاركين في المسابقه يعني نقول نفسي
كيف ساجعل الاحبابي في جنوب افريقيا
الفارقه ايضا ان نشاركوا في هذه المسابقات
وان يحفظوا القران وان يهتموا بعلوم
القران وغيرها فهذا يعني يا زادت لحبي
للقران وايضا يعني
يعني يشعرك انك يعني هناك اناس الله
سبحانه وتعالى استخدمهم للقران واشوف قيمه
كيفهم يعني يخدمون القران يعني
يدرسك يعني هناك درس يعني انك لابد ان
تخدم القران كما ترى مشايخ كبار علماء
يعني متواضعين ويختمون القران فهذا كان
يعني من من الدروس ومن العبر الذي استفدتم
في
مشاركته الدوليه في القران الكريم الحمد
لله يعني في جوني سبيك طبعا هناك
المدن مختلفه اما الطلاب الذين ادرسهم
القران الكريم هم طلاب افارقه الذين ياتون
عندي يدرسون من البدايه
يسلمون عندنا ياخذون الشهاده ينطقون شهاده
ثم ندرسهم النظافه والعقيده والصرا
والاخلاق ومن خلال هذه نبدا معهم التحفيز
من حروف الهجائيه ثم يقراون القران كلها
نظره
بعد ذلك عندما يعني هو يستطيع ان يجيد او
يتقن القراءه القران نظره فهذا من هذا باب
له ان يبدا بتحفيظ القران الكريم
فالحمد لله هذا في نوم في نوع من التحدي
لانه لغه غريبه لم يسمع قبل قبل
وفي اكثر الاوقات ترى تجد ان ابوه او امه
غير مسلمين فانما مثلا الطالب يحفظ جزء لا
يجد هديه من ابيه ولا امه فلا يشعر يعني
كانه فعل شيء عظيم يعني او عندما مثلا انا
عندما انتهيت بالقران
المدرسه هذا
سته كؤوس
ولم اشعر انني حفظت القران مني لان ابي لم
يكن مسلما ذلك الوقت وما احتفل ان ابني
حفز القران ولا امي فهذا هي التحدي خاصه
بالطلاب الافارقه يعني كيف تشعرها ان هذا
كلام الله يعني انت لو حفظت جزء هذا شيء
عظيم فلابد ممكن تشتهي تحفظ جزئين على
الشهر او تحفظ ثلاث اجزاء في هذا الشهر
فهذا هو التحدي ولكن الحمد لله يعني
في مدارس اخرى
لترى ان
الطلاب من بيئه اسلاميه
الهنود المسلمين بجنوب افريقيا فانما يحفظ
في بيته ابوه يحفظ جزء ابوه يعطيه هديه
يشجعه ويرغبه في تحفيز اخره يوصله للمسجد
بعد الصلاه بعد بعد الفجر قبل الفجر بعد
العشاء بعد قبل العشاء فهذا ولكن اما
عندنا فانا من مجالي انا احفز المواطنين
من جنوب افريقيا وهم يدرسون ايضا علوم
كثير مثلا انا كان عندنا شيخ من مصر ظهر
أنا وترى الاحباب ونحن الحمد لله استنفنا
في سويته هذا اكبر حي مدينه في تقريب ممكن
في افريقيا
هذا اللوكيشن
اكبر مدينه يسمى لوكيشن
فحملنا هناك وهناك يسكن الافارقه والناس
كثير جاؤوا وترى هذا لها اثر عظيم الناس
ما شاء الله هم عطشانين يعني يريدون ان
يدرسوا القران وان يحفظوا القران ان شاء
الله
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله
رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم ملك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقي
م صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الض
الين بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
لايلاف قريش
ايلافهم رحله الشتاء
والصيف
فليعبدوا رب هذا
البيت الذي
اطعمهم
من جوع
امنهم
وامنهم
صدق الله العظيم
الحمد لله الجو في جنوب افريقيا في رمضان
جميل جدا ان ترى الناس المساجد ملايين في
صلاه التراويح
والحمد لله الناس يصلون التراويح وايضا
ترى ليس فقط في المساجد ترى ايضا في
البيوت يعني الحمد لله عندنا حفاظ كثير
خاصه في مدينه المسلمين الذين يوجد في
بيئه المسلمين ترى في المساجد الناس يصلون
التراويح في بيوتهم في جماعات كثير وصلنا
في مسجد ترى مسجد في المسجد في الداخل
مسجد يصلون جزء وفي القاعه في نفس المكان
في نفس المكان المسجد يصلون ثلاثه اجزاء
يا الجماعات كثيره الحمد لله هذا هو الجو
في جنوب في جنوب افريقيا في شهر رمضان
الناس ما شاء الله يحبون ان يقرا القران
ويصلون صلاه التراويح وايضا ترى تعامل
مساكين يعني في بطريق جميل بطريق ما تتخيل
يعني الحمد لله ترى مؤسسات المسلمين
يزورون الفقراء والمساكين في اطعام الطعام
وافطار الصائم في المسجد لو دخلت اي مسجد
ترى هناك افطار الصائم بطريقه جميله جدا
فالبيئه والجو في رمضان جميله جدا والحمد
لله المسلمين مرحبين والحمد لله يعني
يقومون
يعني بهذا الجو الرمضان واطعام المساكين
افطار الصائم
احضار الصلوات صلاه التراويح فالحمد
لله يعني الله يجزيهم خير الجزاء ان شاء
الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات